hello and welcome to this video playing
cloth the the indie independent okay who
is that there's no name okay let's see
playing a Queens gambit raleigh or he
may be those for something independent
no particular reason for an idea three
first of gesture yeah i know i just
played it first usually I go c 4 t so he
goes for them he goes in variation I
don't have a particularly great recipe
playing playing classically with III in
Bishop d3 transposing into a new loan
now was intended to see lots of comment
if you find a movement its octopus in
such a position from the Enochian this
looks more normal just develop stuff so
d5 now now we took 95 doesn't work yeah
looks like a Sally normal IQ preposition
we should be seven and so on yeah I was
wondering actually what I do now should
age 40 in G five looks don't believe in
g5 it might work I know it doesn't do it
this
not something I expected so let's see if
you take h4s the only book that makes
any real sense we are taking their there
is no tactic whatsoever night h4 clean
chicks also don't have a tactic so I'm
going here play for them with d5
I will get that inner defies is the next
move nice for me not terrible friend but
to see what movie plays him something
that looks c8 he has to reckon with ed
Alec d5 ed bishop c8 that could even be
a little bit annoying for black and you
created some somehow the most natural
choice here almost ok this one
[Music]
gently five is normal let's do it I
didn't think about that
okay that's that such any playable so I
didn't didn't think about that move
along what what are you doing here mr.
independent whatever but that's wacky I
can check here right what happened jack
[Music]
just might if midnight back home or do I
have something better I can take f7 like
he takes oh that's probably probably
most straightforward him they might move
the Korean I learn bishop g6 okay just
taking everything here let us work wow I
was thinking queen bee three should be
should be terrible for Knight f6 is 77
everything whoa black resin and left
that could work that was a strange thing
and I think you did what is he okay here
if you just like a chick here and he
takes that that's that looked okay they
looked okay I mean okay let's switch the
engine on I saw this and I didn't feel
like I have anything here like cream
cakes okay then oil should be okay for
like with this you should be on the wide
open position group da door something
look see eight he's find them this is
possible given by the comp where it's
tough to say it is a strong or weak and
is roughly equal tapcaf position ard 5
and this just doesn't work ok I can also
move it back a bit well this is the
easiest okay now looky one was even
stronger but this is this is enough he
could have actually taken because from
the of this down it's just an exchange
up for absolutely nothing but we get ok
guys thanks for watching